the first full week of the true off
season Super Bowl was five days ago the
combine is coming up in a few weeks
we'll be there big cat will be there
Sims will be their full-time employee
now of NBC Sports and and once it starts
going you go combine you go free agency
you go the league meeting you got the
draft and then we get into May and
there's still gonna be things to talk
about this thing's still gonna be things
happening in the NFL because the NFL is
the king and the 2018 season was a nice
rebound for the league big cat from what
happened in 2017 as the ratings continue
to go down so let's just have kind of a
free-form discussion here about the
things we'll remember most from the
season that was I'll give you the honors
what's the first thing that stands out
for you other than the surprising and
stunning success of your Chicago Bears
well they they're on the list I'm being
unbiased so I have a full list
I sent the stats there I go all around
the league but I think you can't tell
the story of the 2018 NFL season without
one guy in his Patrica homes I mean he
was the guy he was a big reason for I
think the excitement of the NFL coming
back I think you know the MVP the
touchdowns he is going to be the future
and watching and that's really what the
NFL needed right they need the next line
of quarterbacks to take the place of Tom
Brady Aaron Rodgers Drew Brees these
guys who we've known and watched for 20
years they need the next line and
Patrick mahomes is going to be the top
of that line he is going to be the guy
there's never been a guy who has emerged
the way he has we've seen Dan Marino in
1984 his second NFL season who took the
NFL by storm but he played quarterback
the way that everyone else always had he
just got rid of the ball ridiculously
quickly with mahomes it was something
we'd never seen before the arm angles
the side arm throws the no-look passes
throwing on the run
throwing incredibly accurately under
duress throwing the ball with his left
hand when he needed to we've never seen
this and the thing that I wonder and and
I hope to live long enough to see the
the fruits of this how many kids out
there you know it's almost like when
Michael Jordan came around like people
started playing basketball differently
whether they could or couldn't was a
different issue but he
showed that the human body can do things
on a basketball court that people really
hadn't tried before and I think Patrick
mahomes may be influencing a generation
of kids to try to play quarterback
differently now it's gonna get plenty of
them yelled out by their coach but I
you're gonna see it in backyards you're
gonna see it on youth football field
you're gonna see it in high school and
we're gonna have five Patrick mahomes in
the NFL 15 years from now Mike I know
you don't watch the NBA and you don't
keep up with any other sport besides
football but the apt analogy there would
be Steph Curry because it's literally
right in front of our face Steph Curry
kids now are buying the jerseys trying
to shoot threes everyone's just jacking
up threes from half-court Steph Curry is
the guy in Patrick mahomes
has that cool factor that Steph Curry
has and I think you're right on that
kids are gonna be watching and kids are
going to be into the Patrick Holmes hype
for they're gonna grow up with them they
will grow up with them just like I grew
up with you know the Peyton Manning era
and all this stuff and the Tom Brady
versus Payton this will be the patch
from homes that are calling forward well
the one thing that will always be in my
mind and this is related to Patrick
mahomes because it was a Patrick mahomes
game but week 11 the Monday night game
the epic arguably the biggest
regular-season game since bears dolphins
in 1985 when Miami supplied the only
loss that year for one of the greatest
teams of all time that game 54:51 Peter
King was on this program talking about
how Dan Fouts believes the defense
should be given a 12th man that's how
bad it's gotten by way of skewed in
favor of the offense and then 11 weeks
after week 11 the team that scored 54 in
that game scores three freakin points in
this Super Bowl I mean that that
dichotomy is I'll never that 20 the
first thing I'm gonna think of when I
think 2018 season is the Rams score so
many points in the middle of the regular
season
that causes Dan Fouts to suggest that
maybe there should be 12 guys on defense
and then that team scores three measly
points in the Super Bowl isn't it
perfect that's just so perfect that
whenever we think we've got the NFL
figured out you then have like you said
the 51 was a 51 48 and or was it 54 51
54 21
54 51 and then you have the lowest
scoring Super Bowl
time I love it that's why the NFL you
can't figure it out anytime you think
you got to figure it out you're wrong
there's only one guy that can figure the
NFL out and his name's Bill Belichick
and that was also on my list Bill
Belichick being immortal he already was
probably the greatest coach of all time
but what he did this year with a team
that a lot of people said this is the
year the Patriots get too old this is a
year the Tom Brady starts showing his
mortality
Bill Belichick puts an absolute whooping
on Sean McVeigh and the whole offensive
trend of the league and shows that he is
still king shouldn't they just go ahead
and put Belichick in the Hall of Fame
right now I you know I made the argument
that Tom Brady has to Hall of Fame
careers that that pivot around 2008 when
he had the torn ACL you could put Brady
oh you gonna put one bust in for Brady
now you could put béla check in now I
don't know why I don't know what the
ruse here is cuz Bellatrix gonna coach
until he's 80 and then he's gonna have
to wait five years until he gets in he
may be inducted posthumously I mean at a
bear and I'm being facetious here but
they should whenever he retires they
should instantly put him in the Hall of
Fame they should waive the waiting
period they should have the bust ready
to go because what this guy's done in
this age of salary cap and supposedly
parity and free agency ruining
championship teams I remember those
Cowboys teams after every Super Bowl
there would be a rush by other teams to
sign free agents away from the Cowboys
because it was going to dismantle this
team that Jimmie Johnson had built but
the Patriots had let these guys go we'll
bring in somebody else we'll trade these
guys before they become free agents
we'll get rid of Chandler Jones we'll
get rid of Jimmy Collins we'll get rid
of Brandon cooks we'll get rid of this
guy we'll get rid of that guy and it all
keeps working ya know I actually like
that idea you get every single year the
Hall of Fame you have one guy who you
can vote in whether he retired two days
ago or ten years ago I like that I like
that idea my good good idea you ever
know and then you have a good idea why
then you took my idea and actually made
it better all I'm saying is put
Belichick and Brady and the idea that
there's one guy every year that doesn't
have to wait five years I kind of like
that yes yeah my other one I am gonna
mention the Bears defense because I
think you need to you can't if we're
doing that you can't tell the story of
the 2018
season without these storylines the
Bears defense the way that that you know
the Bears franchise was able to kind of
pivot and rebound off of what's been
very very bad football for a very long
time you know since Lovie Smith and the
Bears went to the Super Bowl and lost
the Colts the NFL loves when the Bears
you look at the season next year you
look at the schedule next year there's
all these big games you look at this
year the the Bears played in a bunch of
primetime games the NFL loves when the
Bears are good the NFL needs the Bears
to be good so I think that if you are
saying well this is the year that the
NFL bounced back with ratings and all
the storylines
I think the Bears were part of that
success oh and I agree and that's why
Matt naggy was coach of the year you
know the coach of the year is always the
coach whose team exceeds expectations
more than any other and no one thought
the Bears would get to the playoffs they
were gonna be fourth place in the
division and they ended up having one of
the best seasons of any team and you
know a bounce of the ball here or there
and they would have had a bye week and
they wouldn't have lost on that double
doink in the wild-card round yeah if you
gotten over that yet it goes as it comes
and goes so there'll be times where I'll
just think of it and get really down so
what you just did right there by
mentioning it that was sorry hair of you
so at least you had the playoff game the
Raiders can't say the same thing and I
remember the excitement last year and
this is my next one the disastrous
return of Jon Gruden to the NFL we
waited nine years he hovered over the
NFL when's he gonna come back when's he
gonna go back he'd waited so long we
kind of just forgotten he was thinking
about coming back and then out of the
blue he gets that fire stoked he told me
last year once they put him in the Ring
of Honor in Tampa that's when he knew he
was coming back we thought he was going
back to the Buccaneers enter Mark Davis
with the 10-year hundred million dollar
contract supposedly and it was
anticipation of what is Jon Gruden gonna
do what are the raiders gonna do and he
just come and I'm a big cat the day that
Matt Negi had his introductory press
conference Gruden's was right after it
and I remember watching Nagy and Gruden
and thinking what with the Bears
thinking doing- Negus press conference
was amateur hour Gruden's was polished
it was great it was inspiring and Nagy
has you know a hundred times better of a
season proving yet again it doesn't
matter what you say at a press
conference what matters is what kind of
decisions you make and Gruden made one
horrible decision after another starting
with the decision to hand Khalil Mac
over to the Bears yeah and Jon Gruden
you're not only talking about the
disastrous things he did with the
Raiders but the ripple effect of what
Jon Gruden did with the rest of the year
you mentioned the Bears if they don't
trade Khalil Mak the Bears are a
completely different team if they don't
trade Amari Cooper the Cowboys are a
completely different team so not only
did Jon Gruden affect his team but he
probably had two teams get in the
playoffs directly because of you know
personnel decisions he made my next one
is gonna be very specific very personal
so just bear with me you can't tell the
2018 NFL season story without Todd
Gurley going down at the two yard line
in week nine when the over-under was 57
and the score was 29 27 and Todd Gurley
never was the same after that remember
he scored every single week leading up
to that so you cannot tell these from a
gambling perspective from a better
perspective you can't tell this season
story without that specific moment and
you know I'm glad you mentioned that
because really 2018 was the year of
gambling and it was the first year that
the NFL embraced it the media is
gradually embracing it and it's just
part of the open discussion it's
seamless now you don't have to like stop
and think am I allowed to talk about
this and we talk about it more and it's
good because it's always been part of it
and so now that even if you're an NFL
partner or not you can get into these
things you can talk about betting lines
you're picking against the spread you're
looking at all these interesting props I
meant to mention earlier did you see the
guy made a hundred grand because he
actually bet on the Rams only scoring
three points at 250 bucks at 400 to one
odds I don't know I don't know I'm
surprised there's only 400 one odds but
you know it's and and here's the thing
and and I guess this is my final one as
it relates to officiating the Rams
Saints call that's gonna hover for years
over the NFL it's damaged some Saints
fans as far as they're concerned but
here's the thing big cat one of these
bad calls if they don't clean up
officiating one of these bad calls is
going to be the one that creates a huge
mess
three NFL because now people have their
hard-earned money legitimately wagered
and as more and more states go online
with legalized gambling you're going to
have and and I know people go nuts when
they say God what Congress has better
things to do eventually there's gonna be
one of these bad calls when there's
enough states that have legalized
gambling that the Commissioner is gonna
get hauled before a congressional
committee and the message is gonna be
you better clean this mess up and
improve your officiating or we're gonna
pass legislation we're gonna create an
agency we're gonna do something to force
you to do a better job of officiating
these games because there's too much
money riding on decisions made by the
officials okay I buy it from that angle
you saw the NCAA basketball actually
just had to have a ruling that they will
review every shot in March Madness
because they've had two times this week
where the final shot counted but it
shouldn't have counted so I agree with
you there and one more point about the
Todd Gurley and officiating you're right
the NFL is King because of gambling and
I know that might be taboo to say but
it's been always out in the shadow it's
been in the shadows now it's come out
this year the NFL is King because of
gambling and that's why everyone in
America watches invests it's not the
only reason but it's one of the biggest
reasons so having that out all on the
open I think it's a good thing for the
league and I agree with you completely
that we're gonna take a quick break one
of the new leagues that is still to come
a year from now the XFL upstaging the
AAF by naming Bob Stoops the coach of
the Dallas still to be named franchise
we'll play some of the best of my intern
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports